- [Reporter] How do you balance
being a player as well as a mother?
- I just, you just do it.
You just get it done and find a way.
What's today, Amaya?
- Game day!
- What?
What is it?
You look so cute.
- [Kristen Ledlow]
Motherhood is a 24-7 job.
When the WNBA announced plans for a
bubble of their own, Dearica Hamby
of the Las Vegas Aces and several
other WNBA players had a difficult
decision to make: opt out of the
upcoming season altogether or opt
in and bring their children into
what's been aptly named the wubble.
- I didn't think we were gonna
have a season this year.
I was debating on if I was
gonna opt in or opt out.
But once I knew that I was gonna opt
in, I knew Amaya would come with me.
- I wasn't sure if I was gonna bring
her or not because I wasn't sure
how safe it would be, but actually
going there and being there, it
was as safe as it could be for her.
Under the water.
Scrub.
- [Ledlow] Once inside the wubble
at IMG Academy in Bradenton,
Florida, figuring out that
work-life balance was no easy task.
- [Dearica Hamby] Parenting in
the bubble was an adjustment.
- [Bria Holmes] It's a tough season.
We're doing pretty well.
It's nothing that we wanted to do.
It's just something that
we have to do right now.
- She's got a lot on
her plate, doing every aspect
of it at a very high level.
- Some of the kids are able
to be there to experience what this
wubble, shortened season is like.
Like how do you keep them entertained?
[Laughing]
- [Ledlow] When you're in isolation,
where your two main jobs coincide,
finding time for yourself can
be the most challenging part.
- I will say it is difficult
when I'm taking a pregame nap,
and she's in PE, and they're
hula-hooping and jumping rope.
And when she's in music class,
and they're doing music, it
can get a little difficult.
- [Hamby] It was an adjustment.
You're getting treatment.
You're coming over to
get tested all the time.
- [Holmes] Shootaround, practice, game.
Shootaround, practice, game.
- And then some days, I just wanna sleep.
- [NAME] It is exhausting to take
care of a three-year-old in life.
And Dearica is balancing that.
She's balancing playing
at a very high level.
And her daughter, Amaya,
is adorable and precious.
And yet it does take a ton of energy.
- I mean, you only practice two
hours out of the day
but it just seems like
you still have no time.
But just kind of being able to
find a balance of keeping yourself
sane and also being able to
contribute to your team success.
Also being able to come
back and be a mom helps.
- [Ledlow] Without day care
services, players have to look
at other means of child care.
Their teammates, friends and
family were ready to step in.
- My teammates, they love her.
That alone speaks for itself.
- [Hamby] Candace was a big help.
We're neighbors.
Her and Lailaa spent a
lot of time with Amaya.
- [Candace Parker] Amaya,
are we friends?
- Yeah.
- [Parker] OK, so, like, real friends
get in an ice bath together.
- I can stand in front of you
and Bryson can stand here.
- [Parker] Yes, let's do it. Come on.
- They just bring so much
joy to everybody in the bubble and
really take the edge off of everyone.
- We got our lucky charm right here.
[Cheering]
- [Holmes] Just having her here, I
feel like that's my stress relief.
When I'm not having a good day or
being able to just see her grow
every day and be here with me.
We're in this bubble while
I'm still doing my job.
I mean, it definitely means a lot,
and I'm glad I decided to bring her.
- Are you dancing?
- [Hamby] I think I will
remember the experience.
I think I've learned that it
truly does take a village.
It takes a lot of people.
And I think this bubble has shown that.
- [Parker] To be in a historic
season in the wubble, I think
we're making the best of it.